الرئيس بايدن موجود في إسرائيل هذا
الصباح بعد أن أصاب الانفجار المميت في غزة
مستشفى مما أسفر عن مقتل المئات، هذا
وفقًا للمسؤولين الفلسطينيين، فنحن
نعرف أن الكثير من الأشخاص ماتوا مئات
الأشخاص ليس هناك رقم مؤكد بعد، لكنه أمر
مفجع ومروع وكان هناك
فظيعًا  الإصابة والموت بعد
ذلك الانفجار والعديد من هؤلاء
الأشخاص الذين طلبوا اللجوء هذه هي
حقيقة الوضع وهذا الانفجار
يثير أيضًا احتجاجات جماهيرية مناهضة لإسرائيل
في جميع أنحاء الشرق الأوسط أه اليوم
أه بدءًا من الليلة الماضية في الأردن
ويستمر  خلال النهار اليوم في
الأردن شوهدت قوات الأمن المحلية
تستخدم الغاز المسيل للدموع لمحاولة تفريق
حشود ضخمة بالقرب من السفارة الإسرائيلية في أمان
وأريد أن أذهب إلى بلدنا اه ناشر
الذي هو في أمان الأردن مع المزيد
وأندت أريد فقط أنتم  أعرف
السياق هنا بالطبع هو أن
رئيس الولايات المتحدة كان
سيذهب إلى هناك بشكل صحيح، وهذا يعطي
الناس سياق ما حدث عندما
حدث هذا الهجوم على المستشفى الذي
تدفق على الفور في
الشارع أه في المدينة التي
كان فيها الرئيس  إن الغضب قد
غليان وقد
رأينا ذلك
يترجم ليس فقط إلى الجبهة الشعبية
ولكن أيضًا إلى الجبهة الدبلوماسية كما
ذكرت تلك القمة بين
قادة مصر والسلطة الفلسطينية
والأردن وبالطبع
الرئيس الأمريكي جو بايدن.  لقد
سمعنا من وزير الخارجية
الأردني بالأمس يقول إن
تركيزهم الوحيد في عقد هذه القمة
هو وضع حد للحرب لإراحة
الشعب الفلسطيني داخل قطاع غزة المحاصر،
وهو لا يشعر بذلك.
لا تشعر السلطات الأردنية أن
شركائها الدوليين على نفس
الصفحة عندما يتعلق الأمر بهذا التركيز في هذه المرحلة
الزمنية وبالطبع
لا يمكننا تجاهل حقيقة أن هذا
جاء ردًا على ذلك
الهجوم المروع على مستشفى ألاهي داخل الأردن.
قطاع غزة نعلم أنه قد تم إعلان 3 أيام من
الصباح وهذا
ملاحظ في جميع أنحاء الشرق الأوسط العلم
خلفي في المنتصف أه ردا
على ذلك الهجوم وطبعا كما
ذكرت رأينا احتجاجات ضخمة
تحدث في جميع أنحاء المنطقة  في الواقع
هذه الاحتجاجات مستمرة منذ
بداية الحرب خاصة هنا
في عمان حيث ما يقرب من نصف
السكان إما فلسطينيين أو من
أصل فلسطيني عبر الأردن أه
بل هذه قضية مركزية
لكثير من الناس في هذا البلد رأيناها ضخمة
حشود تجمعت بالأمس باتجاه
السفارة الإسرائيلية، حاول بعض المتظاهرين
اقتحام السفارة الإسرائيلية،
ونتوقع أن نرى المزيد من
الاحتجاجات اليوم بما في ذلك احتجاج واحد
يقال أنه من المقرر تنظيمه خارج
السفارة الأمريكية، بالطبع يُنظر إلينا على أننا
حليف رئيسي هنا لـ  إسرائيل ومتواطئة إلى حد ما
في ما يشعر به الكثيرون من أن
هذه الضربات الجوية المروعة تحدث
داخل سفينة غزة ولكن أعتقد أنه من
المهم حقًا التأكيد هنا على
الغضب الذي رأيناه بين أه
الناس في جميع أنحاء الشرق الأوسط أعتقد أن
المحلل العسكري الخاص بك قبل قليل
وصفت هذا بأنه تحيز محسوس في
الشرق الأوسط ولكن يجب أن أقول إن ما
رأيناه من الأشخاص الذين
تحدثنا إليهم هو شعور بالرعب
والغضب من الخسائر المدنية التي
رأيناها داخل G  تجريد منطقة من الأرض
الواقعة تحت الحصار، فإنها تواجه
حصارًا كاملاً في هذه المرحلة
الزمنية وأعتقد أنه من المهم أيضًا
التأكيد على أنه في حين ألقت حماس، وبالطبع
في نظر العديد من القادة العرب،
اللوم بشكل مباشر على إسرائيل
نحن نعلم أن إسرائيل نفت بشكل قاطع
أي تطور في هذا الهجوم،
وألقت اللوم على حركة الجهاد الإسلامي في
غزة بسبب فشل إطلاق صاروخ
وفقًا للجيش الإسرائيلي، لكنني أعتقد أنه من
المهم التأكيد على أنه على
مدار أكثر من أسبوع الآن، ما
رأيناه  هل تتعرض المناطق المدنية داخل غزة
لهجمات متكررة من
الغارات الجوية الإسرائيلية، وهذا ليس
وفقًا لحماس
والسلطات الفلسطينية على الأرض في غزة فحسب، بل
وفقًا لمجموعات حقوق الإنسان الدولية
وفقًا للأشخاص الذين
تحدثنا إليهم مع المستشفيات والمرافق الطبية
والمدارس وحتى طرق الإخلاء
يقال إنها آمنة للناس للفرار إلى
جنوب غزة، لذا يمكنك أن تتخيل
الغضب الذي تشعر به في جميع أنحاء الشرق الأوسط
وبالطبع نتوقع المزيد من
الاحتجاجات في جميع أنحاء المنطقة كما
ذكرت، بعضها يحدث بينما نتحدث
في تونس.  سيستمر الناس في النزول
إلى الشوارع، وسيزداد هذا حدة
مع استمرار القصف الجوي الإسرائيلي
على غزة